now I want you to imagine it just really
imagine if these were Christian nuns
getting dirty water thrown at them would
the world be in an uproar think about
that one now where are the main World
human rights organizations the women's
rights organizations speaking up against
this evil that's going on in what's
supposed to be the world's biggest
democracy in India against these Hindu
radical extremists that are persecuting
the Muslim minority and these cowards we
ask them not to wear the hijab when they
attend and the hijab has to be kept
outside the gate have nothing better to
do than to go after innocent women look
the one thing here I'm going to mention
it doesn't solve the issue and
ultimately our help will come from the
creator of the heavens and earth God
Almighty the Creator Allah and for us we
have to be living this Deen but we can
do our small part and make whatever
positive effort we can from our end like
we had our brother professional soccer
football player Paul Pogba recently do
where he used his social media platform
to raise awareness about what's going on
in India now who's Paul Pogba he's the
man the brother who talks about how
Islam how the Quran gave him true
purpose in life I think Islam give me
this um
his guide you know the Quran give me a
guide of who to be and why you are here
in life more than football or any other
sport more than football more than yeah
modern sport the brother who said a
Muslim is one who wants to behave good
and send a good positive message I was a
Muslim wants to behave good and showed a
good example to to the world to all the
people that's what the our Prophet
wasallam used to used to do and we want
to do the same so we commend our brother
Paul bugba for that and inshallah we
have some more people of influence do
their small part of speaking out against
this evil against these cowards going
after our sisters now look at his mob
how many you count how many of these
cowards do you count look at these
cowards look at these you have one
Muslim woman here minding her own
business on her way to school dressed
modestly similar to how the Christian
nuns dressed also like Mary the Mother
Jesus and here come these extremist
Hindu mobs trying to intimidate her now
imagine if there weren't any any cameras
and if they can get away with it the
kind of things that these people would
perpetuate and do to these women because
that's what sick people do these are
sick cowards but my question is where's
your buddy Biden and the bunch we're the
leaders of the Muslim World against as I
started off imagine if this was
happening to Christian nuns religious
God-fearing women or women in general
but they're Muslim women so we'll just
keep our mouths shut and let this evil
perpetuate it's amazing the hypocrisy
and the double standards that we see in
the world today and the feminist
movement the mainstream feminist
movements they're asleep to this now I
usually try to stay calm and collected
but I was just imagining myself there
you know because you watch this and the
blood boils I mean you're a human being
you got emotions and then you see
innocent women over there are sisters
you know getting this dirty water thrown
at them disrespected like this one man
I'm there by myself you're gonna go down
to the end Defending Your sister right
but if I had an All-Star lineup you know
I was just thinking I was like
subhanallah who would that be
and I imagine myself there you know I
had let's say our brother we start off
with if you know these names Habib
and our brother Islam
and Ali kedokov so that's three because
you got I think close to 100 of the mom
and who else can we put in here we get
Sonny B Williams huh and who else
frazabi huh who else would you add to
that hamzat and I think if we had this R
star lineup I think we'd smash these
guys and teach them how to respect may
God Almighty Allah keep our sisters and
brothers in this part of the world this
persecuted minority say protect them and
all those others innocent human beings
who are suffering all over the world all
over the Globe May God Almighty Allah
bring relief and his help and let us do
our small part and do our small effort
to go ahead and make a difference like
our like our brother uses platform Paul
to go ahead and create some awareness
you guys can go ahead and create some
awareness if you knew that this can go
ahead and get you some reward go ahead
and hit the like button share so we can
do our small part and get the message
Out Create awareness of what's going on
in that part of the world and inshallah
we can get more people speaking up and
inshallah we can be living our Deen to
the fullest so inshallah our duas would
get accepted we'll see you next time
until then peace with you